Thank you all for the support. Subs on Twitch and YouTube allow me to keep going and generate
the content. So thank you everybody for the support in tough times. The speedrun continues.
We're 1750 on the nose. Hopefully we get an interesting game. Now before I start the game,
I just want to highlight that as we climb up the ladder, not only do we get more topical openings,
we get more main lines, but also the post-game analysis is more and more focused on explaining
opening theory. So the analysis after the game is going to start getting more technical. And
on the one hand, that is a little bit more boring. On the other, this is what I intended to do with
the speedrun, which is to allow people to build up an opening repertoire essentially from scratch
and without even having to watch supplementary videos specifically dedicated to opening theory,
which also will eventually exist. But that's kind of the zen of the speedrun. And I'll try,
I try to make the analysis as entertaining as possible, but there is a technical component
to it because you really do need to learn a lot of theory if you want to play openings well at
any level. Okay. With that said, let's start the game. Just a moment. Awesome. We're playing black.
Hopefully you can hear me well. We're playing black against Cattle Jewel 1, 1751. And we've
already played him. I can see that we've already played him once. And here we go. 1e3. All right.
Well, we faced this move before. This is, I think, called the Van Cruys opening. It's obviously a
second or even third rate opening, but it's not necessarily a bad move in and of itself. It's,
you know, it doesn't really accomplish much now just so the game doesn't get aborted.
We're going to respond here with Knight, Knight f6. If I remember correctly, the previous time
that we faced e3, I think I played d5, but since my recommendation against 1d4 is the Grunfeld,
we're going to play a Grunfeld or King's Indian setup, which is very effective against 1e3.
And what you should know about the move e3 is that it has very little independent value. And
when that expression is used, what that means is the move often just transposes into one of
several other openings that could be reached via a more conventional first move. So, for example,
if white plays d4 here, that position is incredibly common. It's called the Kali system,
but it's just usually reached via d4, Knight f6, e3. But you should definitely not consider the
move e3 a big mistake and try to punish it at all costs. It's, you know, it's a completely decent
move. Okay, Knight f3. So, there are two very, very good setups, I would say, against Knight f3
and e3. The first one is the more Queen's Gambit or Slav-oriented setup where you play d5 and then
either e6 or c6. If you're a Slav player or you're a Queen's Gambit declined player, well, then you
should have probably played d5 on move 1. But you can also definitely play on move 2. But for the
purposes of this speedrun, we are Grunfeld players. And so, we're trying to be consistent. And so,
the move that we're going to play here is g6. And the Grunfeld or King's Indian setup is
essentially very good against any opening that involves like e3 or c4 or c3. Any opening where
White's pawn is not on e4, you can basically safely play the Grunfeld setup. And that's part
of the reason that I'm recommending it. It's, I think, a very practical choice because you don't
have to learn separate openings and separate lines against every one of White's sidelines.
You can play this against Knight f3 and you can play it against g3 and c4. So, it's a very,
very practical choice. And we have indeed transposed to the Kali system. The Kali system
is, I would say, the cousin of the London. The only difference is that the Bishop remains
behind the pawn chain in the Kali. And that's mostly why it is a lot less popular these days
than the London. But a couple of decades ago, the Kali was an incredibly popular way. It was like
the London of the 1960s and 70s. It is what people played if they wanted to avoid theory and play
something very solid. And generally, this Bishop is fianchettoed in the Kali. It doesn't remain
on c1. And it hasn't been refuted. In fact, I played the Kali in several classical games in
the last US championship. And I won a nice game against Jeffrey Zhang. So, it definitely still
contains a lot of venom. And it's an underrated system. Named after Edgar Kali. Don't remember
his nationality. Might have been German. One of the top players. I don't remember where he lived.
I know he played Alekhine. So, probably early 1900s would be my guess. Bishop d3. Okay. So,
this is, of course, the typical square for the Bishop in both the Kali. In the London,
the Bishop usually is developed to e2. In the Kali, it is often developed to d3. Now,
again, if you're a pure Grunfeld player, then you might be tempted to play d5. And d5 is a
perfectly workable, serviceable move. There's nothing wrong with playing d5 here. But because
of where White developed his light squared Bishop, we're going to modify our opening
strategy a little bit. And we're going to turn this into a King's Indian setup. And most
importantly, you don't really have to know how to play the King's Indian because White's setup
is relatively toothless. So, it's not like you need to know King's Indian theory in order to
be able to play d6 here effectively. You can play the King's Indian setup against certain
offbeat openings and still be a Grunfeld player. Why am I choosing the King's Indian over the
Grunfeld? Well, there's one main reason. And that is because once we play e7, e5, we're going to be
threatening a fork. And that may not seem like a big deal. It's just a tempo. But it's actually
very awkward for White, in many cases, to have to waste another tempo defending against that fork.
I think the King's Indian is an excellent choice against all of these Kali-type setups. And that
is why we are going to play d6. You can also castle here. Both moves are fine. But we're
really just going to declare that for the purposes of this game, we're King's Indian players.
Edgar Kali was Belgian. 1897 into 1932. Yeah, died very young, unfortunately. But already
introduced, you know, left behind a major opening legacy. You might be looking at this and saying,
well, wait a minute, White can push the E pawn one more time to e4. And doesn't that essentially
move order us into a perk, which we don't play? So the answer is yes, sort of. But remember that
White is wasting a tempo playing e3 and then e4. So White will essentially be giving us a perk up
a tempo and a perk in which White develops the bishop to d3, which is far from White's best
setup against the perk. And so e4 is not scary at all. And you can essentially play that like
a King's Indian. So castles, we castle as well. I would say that most King's Indian plans are
divided into two categories. There is sort of bucket one where you play for c5, and then bucket
two where you play for e5. E5 is the more pure King's Indian approach, whereas c5 is often the
choice of Benoni players, right? The Benoni being d4, knight f6, c4, c5. And whether you go for e5
or c5 depends largely often on what positions you prefer, but also on the setup that White chooses.
And as I already pointed out, because of the placement of these minor pieces, I think it's
more effective here to play for e5. Now we cannot play e5 immediately because White's got two
defenders on that square. We need to prepare it. And generally we prepare it either by playing
knight to c6, which is the natural move, or as is often the case in the King's Indian, knight b to
d7. If you've watched King's Indian games, you will know that the knight is often developed
specifically not to c6, but actually to d7. Which of these developing moves we will play depends on,
again, it depends on White's next move. If White plays c2, c4 here, which I think is pretty likely,
then we will avoid knight c6 because that walks right into d5, pushing the knight to an awkward
spot. And that's actually why the knight is often developed to d7, in order to avoid d5 with tempo.
So b3 is our opponent's choice. All right, so that allows us to circumvent the preparatory move. And
these are all things that you would know if you're a King's Indian player. What we're about to play is
kind of basic betty. It's a very standard idea. And of course, as you should notice, b3 opens the
long diagonal. And that allows us to tactically play the move e5 immediately without having to
prepare it. Not that knight c6 would be a bad move. I mean, it's a developing move. But e5
already poses the threat of a fork and confronts White with some specific problems in the opening.
What does White want with b3? Well, probably, I assume he wants to fianchetto his bishop.
Now tactically, this is pretty easy to understand. If White takes twice, who can spot the response
there that wins material for Black? After d, e, d, e, knight takes e5, how are we going to proceed?
So there's a couple of tricks there that you should be aware of. The correct move is knight
f6 to g4. And you need to go specifically to that square. If you go back to d7, then White takes on
d7. And if you take the rook, then the rook on f8 is hanging and White emerges up a pawn. So after
takes, takes, takes knight g4, we are attacking the knight on e5 twice. If knight takes g4,
then we take the rook in the corner, and the bishop evacuates back to g7. We're up an exchange.
If White plays d, e, d, e, knight e5, knight g4, f4, then we will recapture twice on e5. I know
that's a lot of errors, and White will be left in complete shambles in regards to their pawn
structure. I mean, White will also have to play the move c3, which weakens the bishop. That is
a terrible position. Also possible is to meet d takes e5 with the immediate knight g4. And in many
similar types of positions, I'll show you an example, you actually cannot take on e5. For
example, if the White bishop had already been on b2, then recapturing would have made no sense
because we would lose the pawn. So in that case, what you would do is play knight f6 to g4 in this
position, hitting the pawn three different times, and then recapturing it on the next move.
Alternatively, knight f6 back to d7 is a possibility here as well. But because White hasn't
developed the bishop to b2 just yet, we can essentially take a shortcut and take on e5
straight away. So we're threatening e4, and it's not an unstoppable threat by any means,
but it's an annoying threat, and it may force White to make a positional concession. I'm
expecting our opponent to probably go e4 himself, which happens. Nice timing. And I wouldn't say
that Black is better here. Maybe Black is a little bit better, but you should not expect to be,
you know, winning out of the opening against a system as solid as the Kali. You need to be more
patient than that. But we've definitely solved our opening problems. The bishop on d3 is kind of
dumb. We've got a great share of the center, and the position is kind of symmetrical, which means
that we will need to develop efficiently and then try to cause problems for White, probably on the
king side. So next we have to decide where to develop the knight on b8. Again, there's knight
d7, there's knight c6. In this specific position, I don't see a reason for us to avoid the more
natural developing move. It's not like the knight on c6 is vulnerable, and it's a good idea to keep
the diagonal for the bishop open so that we can develop it to g4 or e6 subsequently. So let's
go with the natural move and play knight c6. Alternatively, you could play knight b to d7,
and then fianchetto the bishop, but that would be a little bit too symmetrical for my taste,
and we would be essentially copying White's development scheme, and that's just too boring
for my taste. So let's play knight c6. I wouldn't even say that the Kali is worse than the London,
I think. They're comparable. And like I said, the Kali is a very underrated system. There are
some books on it that came out recently. I'll give you a couple examples. And it definitely
has its share of venom. Now the thing about the Kali is that you can't really play it against
absolutely everything. I think it's less effective against the King's Indian setup
than it is against d4, d5. But much like the London, you can play it basically against
everything, but its strength will vary depending on how Black arranges their pieces. Bishop b2.
Okay, so this is where knowledge of typical King's Indian ideas really, really comes in handy. If
you're looking at this for the first time, this type of position, what kinds of moves are you
likely to think about? Well, you're probably going to see bishop g4, which I don't really like,
because White will play h3. And as I pointed out before, when you fianchetto the bishop,
you have to remember that dropping the bishop back to h5 is no longer a possibility in most cases,
because the bishop gets trapped with g4, and obviously the g6 square is occupied by a pawn.
So queen e7 is tempting, but it's a blunder because of bishop a3, right? Anytime you align
your queen and a rook, and your opponent has a bishop of that color, you need to be mindful.
Queen e7, bishop a3, and if you try to block it with knight b4, White plays c3 and picks up the
knight. So similarly, queen e8 allows bishop a3, and the rook is simply trapped on f8.
Rook e8 is a better possibility, but a little bit toothless. I think we have a better way to defend
the pawn, one that also allows us to start accumulating pieces on the kingside and preparing
for an eventual kingside attack, which is not as distant of a possibility as perhaps some of you
may think. So what move am I hinting at here? I'm hinting at the move knight f6 to h5, which we're
going to play. And this serves two purposes. First of all, it defends the e5 pawn, opening up the
bishop. And second of all, the knight is obviously heading for f4, which is a fantastic square in most
openings, right? That's why Ben Feingold refers to it as knife f5. The f4 square is like, if you want
to blindly put your knight on a particular square in any position, f4 is the square that's
likeliest to be good, because it's just on a great attacking post, it's pressuring the bishop,
it's pressuring g2. It should be pretty obvious to you intuitively why the knight is well-placed
on f4. It's also close to the center, so if white kicks the knight away with g3, not only have we
provoked light square weaknesses on the kingside, but we can deliver a check on h3, or less
adventurously, we could drop the knight back to e6, where the knight is very nicely controlling
some key central squares. So this maneuver with both colors is one that you see in a million
different openings. Ruy Lopez, in the Sicilian, you do get knights on f5, but generally they
appear on f5 through a different square. They take a different route to get there.
But for any opening, there's probably going to be a variation where a knight lands on f4 or f5.
Yeah, also we're preparing potentially f7, f5, again a very typical King's Indian move. With
the d-file being open, f5 loses a lot of its shine, because it's an incredibly weakening move,
and it weakens this diagonal, and white is positioned nicely to deliver a nasty check on c4,
and then you can see that knight u5, knight f7 becomes a problem. So in the mainline King's
Indian, the center is completely closed. White has pawns on d5 and c4. That is why you're justified,
in most cases, playing f5, because white doesn't have access to any critical diagonals. Here f5 is
a lot less likely, but definitely not out of the question, right? If we position our King on h8,
then f5 becomes a serious possibility. Our opponent taking his time, or her time, knight c3.
Great. So that is a normal developing move. The downside is that it blocks the bishop taking
some pressure off of the e5 pawn. I do not see any reason that we should refrain from
continuing to carry out our main maneuver. Yeah, so obviously knight f4 is gonna be our follow-up,
we don't need to take too much time on it. And we're starting to very slowly, gradually,
put a little bit of pressure on white's position on the King's side, in the center.
Now, are we aiming to trade the knight for the bishop? Maybe. Actually, not out of the question.
You might say, well, isn't the knight clearly better than the bishop? Yes, but you have to be
comfortable with the idea of transforming your advantage, right? Sometimes you want to give away
a good piece for a bad piece, because it allows you to gather another advantage. In this case,
like, white will probably recapture with a pawn, and then the pawn on d3 is gonna be a backward
pawn, and we're already aimed at it with our Queen. We can play knight b4 and start attacking
and start attacking that pawn. So you shouldn't, you know, take these trades in a vacuum and say,
well, my knight is good, the bishop is bad, so I'm not gonna consider knight takes d3, right?
There are other factors and other transformations that occur that can justify that trade. Can't
make an omelet without breaking some eggs. And that is one of the key tenets of positional chess
that I think a lot of people are not comfortable with. It's that they take these principles
in isolation, right? Don't trade good piece for a bad piece, don't weaken a square,
but in many complicated positions, you have to violate certain rules and make certain concessions
in order to advance your agenda. Dogmatic is a fantastic word to describe. Dogmatic is a fantastic
word to describe that. 92. And case in point, right? Our opponent is immediately challenging
our knight, so we have a choice. Not responding to this is not an option, right? If we don't
respond, then white will take, and then white will take our bishop, and we definitely don't
want to get rid of our fiend-kettled. Our king is gonna be weak, and our pawn on f4 is gonna be
weak. That's bad. The move queen f6 might come to some people's mind as a way to support the knight,
but I'm not a big fan, because after knight takes f4, queen takes f4, that queen can be easily
tossed back with even a move like bishop c1. So when the queen operates alone like that, it's not
very scary. So there's really only one viable option, which is, in fact, to take the bishop
and to transform our advantage. Yes, we give up our active knight, but we gain the bishop pair,
and we force white to weaken his pawn structure. Yeah. And now the position transforms from,
you know, dynamic to very positional. We're gonna start assembling our pieces in such a way that we
are likely gonna put pressure on the d3 pawn, but without forgetting that the kingside is still
an area of the board that we can operate on as well. So a couple of important points here. Knight
b4 is extremely tempting, but it runs into bishop b2 to a3, which is a move that we have come across
before, pinning the knight. It doesn't win the knight. We can defend the knight with c5, but
allowing that trade is pretty iffy, because the c file opens up, and white can grab it with the
rook. And I kind of want to keep our knight, because the knight is doing some very important
work. It's protecting d4. It's protecting the pawn, and actually, after knight b4, white can
simply grab the pawn. I didn't even see that. So knight b4 is totally out of the question.
A much better idea is to make a developing move, right? We haven't completed our development,
so as many of you are indicating, the most natural and, I think, the best move is just
to play bishop g4 and create the very powerful positional threat of bishop takes f3, which will
obviously completely ruin white's pawn structure and weaken the king. Not so easy to defend
against the threat. If the knight moves back, white drops the d3 pawn. Knight e1 is very passive,
so probably white's going to end up moving the e2 knight in order to protect the other knight with
a queen. But this knight doesn't have too many good prospects either, right? If knight c3,
then we have knight d4. If the knight moves to g3, then it's completely restricted by the pawn
on g6, which is a kind of idea that I've talked about at length. When a pawn and a knight are on
the same file, and there's two squares between them, the knight is often completely restricted
by that pawn. And Aaron Nimzovich, who is a character you should be familiar with,
the author of My System, he kind of famously said that strong players are able to celebrate,
they celebrate every little small advantage. And a lot of games are won through, at a high level,
through the accumulation of small advantages that eventually, taken together, are transformed into
a bigger advantage. This is kind of what's happening here, right? We've got the bishop pair,
the bishop pair, we've got more active pieces, white has a very weak pawn on d3, but our work
is just beginning, because white is still very solid. Knight e1. So knight d4 would be a bad
move because if bishop takes d4, and I see no reason for us to give away the knight,
especially, and close the center, closing our access to the d3 pawn. I think we should make
a general improving move to increase the pressure on d3. What kinds of moves come to mind? Well,
moves that allow the rook to move into d8. The queen on d8 is hogging the best real estate in
town, and I would much rather have a rook on d8 than a queen. A rook is just more effective at
pressuring this pawn. So where should we move our queen? Well, there's a case to be made for queen
d7, and just stacking the queen and the rook. There's also a case to be made for queen e7,
so that after rook d8, the rook is x-ring the white queen. We're also preventing bishop a3
with queen e7. So I think both moves are possible. They're alternatives.
Let me think about this for a second. This is actually not an easy question. Queen g5 is also
interesting, trying to play actively on the king side as well. In fact, I really like the look of
queen g5. It has a little edge to it because we're potentially threatening some bishop h3
shenanigans. It's an adventurous move, but it's not like high risk or anything. The queen can
always drop back to g7. Let's go for it. This is kind of a move in my style.
Queen h4. Yeah, also queen h4 would have been good, but queen h4 doesn't create as many concrete
threats, right? Proximity does not equal activity, right? Just because the queen is closer to white's
king doesn't mean it's better. On h4, the queen wouldn't really be accomplishing anything specific.
What I like about queen g5 is that we're controlling some squares in white's territory,
we're stopping queen d2, and we're x-raying the king. Okay, bishop c1. Great. So,
we induce this move. Yes, this chases the queen away, but now the d4 square
is potentially ours for the taking. Where should we drop our queen back to?
Well, we can play queen h5, but that runs into f3, and then the queen is really offsides.
So I don't like queen h5. I think we should go back to e7. I think now is the perfect time
for us to move the queen back and position it in the center, and we forced white's bishop
onto an inferior spot. Now, the bishop could move along to e3 from where it would defend the d4
square as well, but I would argue that the bishop on b2 is a little bit better placed because it,
well, it puts pressure on the e5 pawn. So we're continuing to squeeze the position and continually
inducing concessions, and eventually we're going to get our opportunity to cash our advantages in.
You just have to be very patient. We're only 14 moves into the game. All right, so let's continue
by putting a rook on d8. Also interesting, by the way, is the immediate f5, but let's try to play a
little bit more positionally. Which rook should we put on d8? Well, in order to determine that,
you have to ask yourself, what is the other rook going to be doing? If we play rook a d8,
well, the other rook might potentially be supporting f5, but I actually like rook f d8,
and the reason why is that later on in the game, maybe even on the next move, we will have the
opportunity to run this a pawn up the board, which is a very classic positional idea, right? Using
the pawn as a battering ram in order to soften up your opponent's position and your opponent's pawn
structure, and this is an idea you're most familiar with in the context of an attack, right?
You do this in order to break apart the king's pawn cover, but you can also do this on the queen
side. You can do this on the other side of the board, and it largely has the same idea. Just
because there's no king on that side of the board doesn't mean it's not an effective plan,
and I'm sure you've seen in top-level chess this kind of plan in action, right? a5, a4 are open
in the a file, and the side that has more active pieces generally benefits from direct contact
between the two armies. Yeah, so clarification, f5 here, after h3, bishop h5, g4 would no longer
be possible, so no, that doesn't blunder the bishop. f3, okay, so white chases the bishop away
but weakens his king side even more. There's only one reasonable square for the bishop, h5 blunders
it to g4. Bishop d7, bishop c8 are needlessly passive. Bishop e6 is a no-brainer, and what I'm
noticing is that yes, the bishop is kind of biting on granite, but that situation could change. If
our pawn was on a4 right now, it would combine very nicely with the bishop to exert tremendous
pressure on the b3 pawn. Also important is that we are covering the d5 square, which means that
the knight on e2 doesn't have as many prospects. Otherwise, the knight would have potentially aimed
for d5. Now its access to that square is barred. White's position is terrible, and what's instructive
about this is that everything's defended. It's not like the win is going to happen in two moves,
but white's just got no active prospects, no plan, and we have such clear ways of improving
our position. So this is where you have to be patient, and you have to understand that your
opponent is actually totally miserable, even if you're not seeing exactly how you're going to win
the game. You don't need to see that. You need to, you know, celebrate the small advantages.
Okay, queen d2. Now there are many good moves in a position like this. A straightforward plan
would be to double rooks on the d-file. Nothing wrong with that. The issue with that, to me,
is that even after we do that, we're not going to be threatening to take on d3 because of this
knight on e1, which is actually a good defensive piece. I mean, that piece is saving white's life
right now. I think we should go ahead and open up another front and spice things up a little bit on
the queen side with what move? Well, it's the move that I just mentioned. I think it's a perfect
opportunity for us to play a5, aiming for a4. Now, again, bishop g5. Did we just blunder an
exchange? No, and for several reasons. First of all, we can play f6. Ain't nothing wrong with
that. But more importantly, we have queen c5 check. f6 is a move that we would like to avoid
because we'd like to keep the bishop on g7 unobstructed in order to exert maximum control
over the d4 square. What about knight b4? Well, knight b4, I don't love because of a3,
right? Knight b4 is a move that we would play if it directly attacked the d3 pawn. I think it's a
little bit impulsive, and guess what? We can play knight b4 a little bit, and white panics, right?
And this is always what happens in these types of games. This happens, I would say, at all levels
under 2,000, where people crack very quickly under pressure, and understandably so, because
you want to get active at all costs, and so you do something impulsive or irrational, and you
blunder something. Now, f4 is just a blunder, and not only does it blunder an exchange, it actually
blunders a full rook because white's rooks are disconnected. So the knight on e1 is the bane
of white's existence now, or white loses a piece. The game is over. Now, if the white knight had
been on f3, interestingly enough, f4 would not be such a bad move, because imagine if white would
be able to recapture the dark-squared bishop on a1, right? Then we would be left without a
fianchetto bishop, and our dark squares would be glaringly weak. This is a very common idea for
white in many openings that involve a kingside fianchetto, such as the Grunfeld. And it's a
blunder. I think our opponent might resign here. Yeah, total collapse, and I wouldn't say that
we're winning here. We'll check the engine eval. My guess is about minus 1.5, so obviously the
computer is able to survive these types of positions, but you should take the engine eval
with a grain of salt, because this is virtually unplayable for a human. But yeah, too passive,
right? Our opponent was too passive from the start, and we didn't do anything extraordinary.
We just improved our piece placement, we induced some weaknesses, and our opponent cracked.
Yeah, and obviously some people watching on YouTube might be like, well, I don't get 1750s
with blunder like this, but again, you weren't sitting there in front of the white pieces
suffering under pressure and spending all of your time trying to find ways out of it. You're
fatigued, and all of us can relate to that type of situation where passive play and suffering often
leads to a blunder. Yeah, definitely I would have loved to continue putting pressure. It's sad that
our opponent blunders the rook here, because it doesn't allow us to continue the kind of
positional squeeze, and I definitely wanted a game like that where we win purely positionally
by squeezing the life out of our opponent. But it is what it is. This is reality.
And the other thing I'd say, our opponent, I think, is going to resign here,
is that when you watch a Magnus game, you might be discouraged, because you might see a 70-move
game where Magnus squeezes a small advantage out of the endgame, like he did against me in the
PCL game today. Remember that at your level, you're likely not going to have to pressure
somebody for 70 moves. If you play good positional chess, this is a more likely scenario. Like a
blunder on move 20 or 30 is a lot likelier than perfect defense, because you're not playing Wesley
So. Bishop g5. So again, we have two choices. We have queen c5 check, and we have f6. Both moves
are totally sufficient. Let's play f6, because it comes with tempo. No, not bishop f6. Bishop f6
blunders the bishop, because white has two defenders on that square, and black has only one—
two attackers. Black has only one defender. Bishop ch4. Okay, so we're up a rook, but that doesn't
mean the factory stops. We still are doing what we were doing. It's just we're doing it now with
an extra rook. But before we continue on the queen side, I think it's prudent to address the problem
of the bishop, because that bishop could get stuck on white side of the board, and the last thing we
want right now is to lose that bishop. So there's like a million good moves here. The Russian school
boy approach is just to drop the bishop back onto a defended square. If you want to win the game
faster, the move that I really have my eyes on is actually bishop e6 to g4, which is what we're
going to play. I would say that this is not an easy move for, you know, a 1700-1800 player to
come up with, because it doesn't seem like it does anything, but it actually does a lot. It
pressures the e2 knight, and right now our main goal is just to simplify. But the second thing
it does is it creates the threat of queen takes e4. How did I see that? Well, I noticed the x-ray
between the rook and the queen, and anytime you see that, you should spot ideas like queen takes
e4. The pawn is essentially pinned. Knight g3. Our opponent contorting himself to keep all the
bases covered, but now I'm looking at the bishop, and I'm noticing that it's trapped. It has no way
back, so we don't need to do this. Again, we could like play bishop d4 and win normally,
but the one thing you shouldn't assume is that when you're up a lot of material,
you shouldn't take free stuff. That's never the right approach. You shouldn't go out of your way
to pick up poisoned pawns, but if there's like a piece lying by the side of the row, there's no
reason not to take it. Yeah, the game is over. Knight f5. We can even play queen takes e4 here.
That would be a fancy move, but more utilitarian is just to take on f5 and take on h4, and we are
not worried in the least about our quote-unquote king weakness because white has no pieces left,
and we can always tuck the king away on h8. Our opponent has defended valiantly, but ultimately
this position is totally hopeless. Queen h6. No threats, right? This move carries zero threats.
Do not be afraid by the appearance. Again, as I said earlier, a lot of people, they see a move
like this, and they start panicking or freaking out. Ask yourself, what is the actual threat?
Does white even have any mating constructions here? The answer is no. g5 is covered. g6 is
covered. Rook h5 does nothing, so there's no reason to do anything drastic here,
which is not to say that you shouldn't ensure the safety of your king or play with an abundance of
caution. You should, and we will, and we will by just tucking the king away into the corner,
right? Just to make sure that there are no shenanigans down the g-file.
And of course we can then play rook g8 and turn the attack back on white. We don't give a damn
about this pawn. It matters for nothing. There are a thousand ways to win a position like this.
I repeat this every time that I win with like a ton of extra material. Don't feel like if you come
up with a move and I don't play it that your move is wrong, right? We're up a rook and a piece.
There's going to be like eight or nine moves that are approximately equivalent in strength.
The way that we're going to play this is to go after white's king. Using the semi-open g-file,
we're going to play rook g8. And we're going to keep an eye out for moves that simplify.
Like if white plays knight f3, which he just did, what move is like an automatic response
that clarifies the position? And this is a move that you should just like see instantly. Yeah,
knight d4, very nice. Knight d4, forcing the trade and leaving white without minor pieces.
Yeah, force trades when possible, but don't go out of your way to do that. Okay, obviously that
also blunders the rook. We can also take the knight, it does not matter. But if we want to
be really sexy, or if we want to get ourselves a nice Valentine's Day date, can anybody spot a
move that just ends the game in style? All right, earlier I was asked if chess is an art. These
types of moves is really what I live for. Absolutely unnecessary, but still pretty.
Noticing that the king on g1 is vulnerable to forks. Yeah, a couple of you have spotted it,
bishop a1 to c3 is really pretty. Queen takes c3, knight e2 picks up the queen.
Importantly, notice the role that the f6 pawn plays. If the f6 pawn was not there,
then queen takes c3 would pin the knight, knight e2 would be illegal. So do this, you know,
this is professionals only. Don't try this at home. Now we take the rook, we infiltrate with
our queen, and now we double, okay, white resigns, we would have played rook ae8 and probably just
gone queen e1 to simplify. OJax asks, what is the point of saying you should see this move
immediately when you very well might have viewers that don't? So when I say that, obviously, I'm
addressing players of the level that we're currently at, just to be totally clear. So like,
if I say you should see this immediately, I'm referring to players of like the 1700 level,
plus, if you're a beginner, and you hear that, hopefully, you know, you're motivated and you're
like, well, I want to see that immediately. And you ask yourself, well, why don't I see that
quickly? And I'm not trying to like condescend or suggest that you're you suck. Like, I'm just
trying to help people understand what are the basics and what do you need to prioritize in
terms of your board vision. Let's take a look. This was a pretty straightforward game. So we
won't go crazy with the analysis here. I'm just going to show you a little bit of the
game. So we won't go crazy with the analysis, but just a couple of important points.
So E3. Again, there's a bunch of moves that you could play here. Now E5, I think is overrated.
I would not play E5. This is a reverse French, but white is an extra tempo. So if you want to draw,
like, obviously, like you can play like this. But you know, get me out of here. This is not
what I would recommend for anybody. This is reverse exchange French. And this is just not fun.
Also possible is D5, as I pointed out at the start of the game. And white likely plays D4,
transposing into a Kali system. So we decided to play a la Grunfeld with Knight F6. Our opponent
responded with Knight F3. I think previously we faced the Hippo setup with D3, B3, and G3.
You can take a look at that game, which is up on YouTube here. White played a little bit more
conventionally. So Knight F3, G6, D4, Bishop G7. This is all normal. Bishop D3. Now, to my knowledge,
Bishop D3 is, believe it or not, already an inaccuracy. As I explained, because it puts
these minor pieces on awkward spots, the theoretical move here is Bishop to E2. This is how Kali
players actually play it. And after castles, white did everything right except put the bishop on D3.
After D6, B3, this is the main line. And as in the game, we can still play E5 here.
And you can dig around online, but I think this position is very popular. And here,
black has essentially a choice between keeping the pawn on E5. But the way I like to play it
is drive the pawn down to E4, which reaches a sort of a reverse French position that is very
common in the King's Indian attack against the French. So this structure is a lot more common
with colors reversed. What am I talking about? Well, in the French, white can play the move D3,
which is the King's Indian attack. And the main line here is C5, Knight C6, Bishop G2.
And in this position, white typically plays E5 and supports it with Rook E1.
And I think I've even had this type of position in the speedrun.
There's a very famous Bobby Fischer game that you can take a look at to acquaint yourself with
the typical ideas here against Miyagimura Suran in the Olympiad in the 60s. But I don't want to
delve too deeply because this is like separate territory. So I think we'll probably get more
chances to talk about these structures later on. For the purposes of this game, let's stick with
Bishop D3. So we play D6, white castles, black castles. And here, if you turn on the engine,
you will see that E4 is the engine recommendation. And I agree with that. I think white should play
E4 here, even though it's a pretty innocuous setup. It's still essentially a perk, and I think
this is the only way for white to try to justify the placement of the Bishop on D3. So what would
we do after E4? Well, let me actually take a look at what players have done. Can you play E5 anyway
here? Yes, you can, although it's complicated. So if you play E5, no, I don't actually think you can,
because after the trade, there is an important distinction between this position and the
King's Indian. Here, knight takes E4, which is the typical response, runs into knight takes F7,
simple desperado sack, and white picks up a pawn, right? You have to take, and well,
white takes on E4 and whites up a pawn. If you compare this to the King's Indian exchange
variation, and this is why it's so important to look concretely rather than borrowing ideas
blindly from opening to opening, there's going to be small details that you might miss
which make a certain idea possible in one position. Here, you can play E5. What's the
difference? Well, in the exchange variation, if white grabs on E5 and we take on E4, and white
plays knight takes F7, common mistake for beginners, who can tell me why this doesn't work here?
Black to play and win. Pause the video if you're watching on YouTube.
So it's not knight takes E3 because that gives up the rook. It is bishop takes E3 because that
is a check, eliminating the attacker. Now you pick up the knight and you're up a piece.
So in a weird way, the fact that the knight is not developed actually benefits white
in the context of this position. So here, you just don't have that equivalent move,
bishop takes E3 or whatever. Also, the knight on E4 is hanging, so that's a difference as well.
Knight takes F2 does not work because after rook takes F2, rook takes F7, I think the simplest is
just to trade and then win the game with bishop takes G6, picking up the queen. So you should
stay away from E5 immediately, but there's no reason to rush with E5. Let me look up what
the engine gives here, just a moment. I'm going to check what the main line is in this position,
so I don't say anything false. Okay, so this position has occurred a bunch of times,
well over 1,000. Magnus Carlsen had this against Dimitri Kollar in a title Tuesday,
but what's hilarious is that most of the time, this position occurs with white to move,
right? Because it comes from a perk and with white to move, usually white plays C3.
With black to move, there's significantly less position, less instances of this occurring,
and the engine actually proposes the move C5, which makes a lot of sense here in order to
pressure the d4 pawn, getting almost a good version of a Sicilian dragon. If white takes on
C5, then we take back and we're doing great, we get our knight out, etc. If white pushes,
then of course we play this Benoni style with E6. And when I use that term, Benoni style,
what exactly do I mean? Well, the modern Benoni goes d4, knight f6, c4, now c5, d5, and e6. This
is the main, the entrance point to the Benoni. So this is a very common idea in King's Indian
positions as well. The two openings are very closely related, and the bishop is usually
fianchetto in the Benoni as well. So after c5, d5, we play e6, and I think the position is about
equal. If white takes on e6, then I would probably take with a bishop, just to keep your pieces
developed. Then the typical plan here is to eradicate the backward pawn on d6, with knight
c6 followed by d5. Essentially, white cannot prevent you from playing d5. Black is very
comfortable here. Now, white should probably go c4, which is the more principled move.
But even here, it's like a great version of a modern Benoni. And here, I like the simple
rook e8, or maybe e takes d5 first. But I like rook e8, because that's a bit of a clever move,
preparing to take on d5, and preparing to put pressure on e4. And after knight c3,
we play e takes d5. And if white plays cd, then you take the opportunity to get rid of your
light-squared bishop. Bishop g4 takes f3, and then the knight can go out to e5. You can dig around
here a little bit on your own, but the engine gives equality here. I actually would prefer
black, because just black has more dynamic plans in this position. If white plays e takes d5,
then I don't think anything changes. I think you still play bishop g4. You eliminate the knight,
and then you drag your knight over to the center, knight b to d7, knight e5, with a very comfortable
position for black. So these are just some possible continuations. The takeaway is that e4,
I think, should be met with c5. e4 should be met with c5. And I would highly advise you, if you're
like a little bit unsure about some of these moves, to set this up on chess.com and take 5-10
minutes and analyze this on your own. But this is not common enough to warrant like a 30-minute
analysis session. So when the game white plays b3, allowing us to push e5 straight away, the
position is still equal, but I already think white needs to be careful. So once again, after d, e, d,
e, knight takes e5, runs into knight g4, attacking the knight twice. And after knight takes g4,
bishop takes a1, a very important detail, c3 is a scary move, because it traps the bishop. But it
weakens the bishop on d3 and allows bishop takes g4. Black wins the piece. I had to see this when
playing e5. This is important. So I don't think knight e5 works. The engine confirms it. Of
course, white can play down an exchange, and white has a pawn for the exchange. The game is not over.
Like, objectively, black is only slightly better, but this is not, you know, challenging. And this
means that the bishop can evacuate back to g7. So for that reason, I think e4 was correct.
We played knight c6. And the question now is, where did white start going wrong? Bishop b2 is
obviously a reasonable move. And after knight h5, I already think that white needs to be
very accurate to avoid slipping into a bad position. Believe it or not, and I just confirmed
this with the engine, knight c3 is already kind of inaccurate. But white is already worse in this
position. Maybe this was the last chance to equalize. And I think the same move should have
been played both in this position and in this position. White should have essentially aimed
to immediately discharge as many pieces as possible, because the knight's coming in,
the pressure is building. White needs to try to trade queens here. So who can spot a very, like…
I mean, it's a move that's probably on your radar, but it might not seem like anything special,
and yet I think it's very important for white to play this move.
So you're almost there. Bishop c4 or bishop b5. The reason I think bishop c4 is better is because
after bishop b5, black can play knight d4. And this bishop is just sort of very… it's actually
very awkward, and queen g5 will hit the bishop. I think the bishop is just safer on c4. But it's
the same idea, you're just trying to trade queens. And the issue is that if black tries to evade the
queen trade, you're walking into bishop a3 again. If you play queen f6, well, then you're pinning
yourself, and knight c3, knight d5 comes with tempo. Though probably we would have played bishop
g4, trying to trade on our own terms. But I think this endgame is holdable. I mean, I think that
black might be a tiny bit better here, but white remains very solid. Knight bd2, we would have
played knight f4, and the knight is very good even in the endgame. And the game continues.
The engine gives g3 here, chasing the knight away. Obviously, when the queens are off the board,
this is a move that you can play a lot more comfortably, because the light squares
are not as important. Black doesn't have the firepower to attack.
But after knight e6, we go over to d4, and it's still an unpleasant position.
It's still an unpleasant position for white, much easier to play for black.
But that definitely would have been the way for white to stay alive.
Here, once again, after knight f4, bishop c4, I think is very important. Although already in this
position, we have the option of going knight to d4. And this appeals to me a lot more with the
knight on f4. John Mickle asks, what if g3 after knight h5? Well, if g3, we would definitely play
bishop g4, hitting the now-exposed knight on f3. And this gets really nasty. And probably white
has to go here. But now we can refrain from the queen trade with a move like queen c8.
And white's just so weak on the light squares. And this could, like, deteriorate very quickly.
Bishop h3, and even knight f4 is a typical type of move here. And obviously, if white takes,
white gets checkmated. So in most middle games, when you play the move g3 and you don't have a
bishop on g2, it's just dreadfully, dreadfully weak. Okay, so our opponent played knight c3
and allowed this trade. And after bishop g4, the situation is already critical for white.
Knight e1 is a good move. Queen g5, I think, is a good move by us. h3, there's bishop takes h3.
So bishop c1 back to e7. We bring our rook into the game. And all of our subsequent moves were
incredibly natural. f3, bishop e6. And I evaluated this position correctly. It's minus 1 or so
according to the engine. But as I explained, practically, it's much harder to play than that.
That doesn't tell the whole story. The correct move for white here would have been rook b1.
Who can explain the idea of rook b1? Why? Why rook b1? And it doesn't solve white's problems,
but it keeps white in the game. Take the sting out of a4, very nice. Type 2 prophylaxis.
You don't prevent a4. You can't prevent a4. If you play a4 yourself, you blunder the pawn.
But you take the sting out of it, because now a4 meets with b4, and white is okay. White keeps the
queen side intact. So here black should be patient. The engine recommends now playing knight b4,
which I really like. After a3, just go back to c6, inducing a huge weakness on a3. And white is just
in a dreadful state here. So we have a lot of options. We can play a5, also good, doubling
rooks. So here we would have continued massaging and squeezing the advantage. But, I mean, this
is almost unplayable. Even queen b4 is a good move. And in the event of the trade, this is a fork on
two pawns. So just like a million options here, and this is very easy to play. We have a couple
of questions. First question, value.1 asks, he didn't fully explain why g3 is so bad. It seems
like white isn't busted concretely. I don't get it. Okay, so to be clear, this is, I assume, g3 move
10. I'm not suggesting that white is losing here. In fact, I'm not even suggesting that it's like
that bad. What I'm saying is that white creates long-term weaknesses, and these weaknesses can
haunt white for the rest of the game. And even though you might not see the win in the next
five moves, that win could come 15 moves down the line. So you should divide advantages into
two categories in your mind, static and dynamic. Static advantages are essentially permanent.
They're likely to last for most, if not all, of the game. This is an example of a static
advantage. Now, can you devise a scenario where white solves the problem of these squares? Yes,
you can. If the queens get traded, these squares are no longer that significant.
But most likely, they're going to haunt white for a long time. What's an example of a dynamic
advantage? Well, an example would be a development advantage, something that is very likely to
evaporate in the next couple of moves unless you act on it. So a development advantage or an
initiative where you're calling the shots, that's an example of a dynamic advantage.
You want to try to avoid, as a general rule, giving your opponent static advantages,
because those advantages pile up, and that's what causes your position to ultimately collapse.
Okay, that's a lot of, I know that's a lot of, you know, babbling, but I just want to lay out
this concept, and then we will expand on it as we raise our rating, because this is going to get a
lot more important. Second question, what makes the pawn on d3 weak? Well, the definition of a
weak pawn is a pawn that cannot be protected by any other pawns. Now, that should be taken with
a grain of salt, because you could look at this and say, well, wait a second, all three of these
pawns cannot be defended by their neighbors, but they're not really weak, right? Because they can't
be attacked, and they're protected by other pieces. The d pawn is genuinely a weakness,
because a, it can't be protected by any other pawns, it's a backward pawn. b, the square in
front of it is controlled very nicely by black. c, this pawn is on an open file, which makes it
very easy to attack, and for those reasons, and it's a center pawn, right? A center pawn being
weak is a much bigger deal than an a pawn being weak, because even if you lose an a pawn, it's
often not the end of the game. And there is no light squared bishop to defend the pawn, so these
factors make the pawn on d3 a huge weakness. So, that is essentially the ideas. Yeah, queen g5 was
not mandatory, we could have just played queen e7, don't freak out that you didn't spot this move.
The idea was literally just to, like, intimidate our opponent, and get him to bring the bishop
back. Okay, we've got a couple more questions. SpikedPunchMan asks, can't you just push the
pawn, and trade central pawns if you're worried about losing it? Well, not really, right? White
can't play d4, it's just not possible, because here we take on f3, and we play e takes d4.
If white plays it on the next move, again, it's not, clearly not possible, because we're pinning
the knight. Yeah, so, this is also, you should notice a similarity with the IQP structure,
isolated queen pawn structures. The way to evaluate them is often to understand
whether, who controls the square in front of the isolated queen pawn. If it's the side with that
pawn, then the weakness often becomes the strength. In fact, our previous speedrun game,
I might remind you, featured exactly that kind of scenario, where we have a pawn, it's isolated,
but we push the queen away, and we're able to push that pawn forward, and then that pawn actually
becomes the bane of black's existence, because it just tosses black's pieces around. So, that's the
concept of blockading, right? That's why it's so important to control the square in front of a weak
pawn, so that you can properly attack it. It's harder to shoot at a moving target. Where's the
blunder? Well, our opponent didn't make a blunder until f4, right? f4 is a blunder, but the position
was already in dire straits. It was a series of small positional errors. And finally, I'm just
checking to see if there are any other mistakes, or any other questions. Yeah, I think we'll stop
it here. Last question from Betelguski. Is there positions where it would make sense to play Bg4,
h3, Bh5, g4, Nxg4? Yeah. So, last topic, I pointed out that in such positions, when you have a fianchetto,
you want to avoid dropping the bishop back in response to h3, because after g4, the bishop
is trapped, and it's trapped because the pawn on g6 blocks its escape. So, for any rule that I share,
like literally anything that I say, an exception can be found, and a situation can be found.
I don't think I'm going to find anything. Well, let me see if I can
finagle a little search here. Just give me a moment. It's running the search.
Yeah, I think I'll take a rain check on this. I'll see if I can run a search on my own time,
because, you know, people watching this on YouTube, I value your time as well. So,
I will try to find an example of this in preparation for the next video.
We're going to pause here, folks. But the upshot is that for anything I say,
there are exceptions, and you should not be dogmatic, right? Every position should be
considered concretely. Hopefully, you enjoyed this positional squeeze. It was a simple game.
I might be back late tonight if I'm not sleepy, but most likely, I will see you tomorrow. I'll
do Arena Kings in Russian. Arena Kings in Russian as usual. That's noon tomorrow. And on that note,
folks, I want to thank everybody for watching. This was a more technical game, but hopefully,
you enjoyed and found it instructive. Thank you, everyone who subscribes on YouTube. I will raid
Benjamin Feingold. I will be commentating the Pro Chess League. So, I will see you on commentary
tomorrow with Tanya Sajdev. Thank you all, and thanks for hanging out. Enjoy.